notre invité nos âmes anwar ancien
policier éditorialiste aux médias re
bonjour est ce que vous pensez que cette
décision d'interdire ce rassemblement à
jouer justement est bien dans les airs
que l'on peut apercevoir à présent
aujourd'hui
évidemment parce qu'en fait il faut
comprendre la position si vous voulez de
la diplomatie française depuis on
réalité depuis 1967 ca depuis la guerre
de six jours c'est que avec des épisodes
on va dire de turbulences la france la
politique française est hantée en
réalité la politique intérieure en tout
cas est principalement pro-israélienne
c'est à dire que bon on voit bien que
les le discours en réalité du miz de
l'intérieur est scandaleux du point de
vue du droit c'est à dire qu'on se base
sur une expérience qui est celle de 2014
et d'ailleurs qui concerne pas paris 1
je rectifie le propos mais qui concerne
manifestation qui s'est déroulée à
sarcelles et pour interdire en fait la
manifestation qui a eu aujourd'hui
s'appelle tout simplement un procès
d'intention c'est que les manifestants
d'aujourd'hui va vous les avez vu son
très jeune donc en 2014 et pas forcément
l'âge de manifester c'est pas forcément
les mêmes
et le monsieur qu'on vient d'entendre
avant trentaine avec quelqu'un de tout à
fait pacifiste avec ces mots il exprime
une position qui est tout à fait
cohérent c'est être que lui il dit on a
besoin d'exprimer justement notre
solidarité et notre indignation quant
aux images justement qui nous
parviennent de ce qui se passe dans la
bande de gaza et sur les territoires
palestiniens savent que c'est pas un
monstre
il vient saccagé paris et comme le
disait votre invité faire des barbecues
halal je ne sais quoi je veux dire c'est
quoi ces expressions c'est quoi cette
façon de considérer les gens qui ont
tout simplement une expérience une
comédienne opinion qui veulent exprimer
par des moyens légaux
en l'occurrence les manifestations de
voie publique des manifestations en
faveur en soutien au peuple palestinien
on en a vu partout dans le monde on en a
vu aux états unis en turquie au royaume
uni en afrique du sud
partout ailleurs ça a été autorisé et en
france
interdiction de manifester ce qu'est ce
que ça veut dire donc on je le le
ministre de l'intérieur dit pour
justifier cette interdiction
justement il évoquait ces troubles à
l'ordre public en 2014 donc vous le
disiez à sarcelles ce que ça montre pas
quelque part un espèce de désaveu sur
les capacités de maintien de l'ordre de
l'état français ça veut dire que là les
policiers français les forces de l'ordre
françaises ne sont pas en capacité de
gérer une manifestation aujourd'hui et
parce qu'on ne peut pas gérer cette
manifestation donc on va interdire
toutes les manifestations qu'on pourra
qu'on sera pas en mesure de gérer alors
je poursuis alors je poursuis mon
raisonnement justement c'est qu'en fait
monsieur darmanin est en train d'envoyer
un signal aux autorités un signal en
fait de solidarité aux autorités
israéliennes qui sont ou ont été
d'extrême droite c'est à dire que le
likoud et peint parti de gauche si vous
voulez donc globalement on l'a vu avec
manuel valls qui a qui s'exprimait sur
les réseaux sociaux
une façon dirais non seulement
catastrophique 1 je vais pas rappeler
les faits ils envoient bâtiments
palestiniens en feu et on voit ça un
signal de moyens un message de soutien
inconditionnel à l'autorité israélienne
et votre invité précédent l'a rappelé
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui en france
quand vous êtes indignés par la
situation et que vous exprimer une
sympathie à l'endroit de la population
palestinienne vous êtes soit du hamas
c'est à dire un terroriste du hamas soit
un islamo gauchiste et qu'il faut
revenir un petit peu de sérieux
j'en veux dire sur les le respect
justement de la liberté de l'expression
et des libertés fondamentales en france
dont la liberté de manifester donc ça ça
s'appelle un procès d'intention moi je
pense que le tribunal administratif
pourra facilement à annuler toutes les
décisions qui vont être prises
aujourd'hui sur justement les
verbalisations de manifestants et sur
les interdictions de manifester ce sera
facilement démonter par juré un avocat
compétent parce que c'est complètement
absurde de se servir justement d'un
problème particulier qui concernait une
situation particulière en 2014 pour en
faire une jurisprudence et interdire
toutes les manifestations pro
palestiniennes en 2021
ça n'a absolument aucun sens d'ailleurs
je tiens à vous signaler que balcon
cause
hasard des circonstances c'est moi
fonctionnaires de police du
renseignement qui est annoncé par un
flash ce qu'on appelle un flash la
manifestation de sarcelles en 2014
et cette manifestation avait lieu à
l'initiative de la ligue de défense
juive et non pas à l'initiative des
organisations pro-palestiniennes et
effectivement elles ont dégénéré
pourquoi parce que le dispositif de
maintien de l'ordre
à sarcelles a été sous-estimée par la
ddsp 95 à l'époque à l'appréciation des
services de renseignement et ce sont les
services du 93 qui sont venus en urgence
toutes affaires cessantes pour justement
renforcer le dispositif de façon
improvisée
donc ça a été justement un fiasco pour
le maintien de l'ordre à l'époque
et effectivement je dirais que les
voyous qui ont brûlé la synagogue et le
nahouri market sont seuls responsables
de leurs actes d'ailleurs on ne sait
même pas s'ils ont été interpellés à ce
jour ou pas et bref faire ce parallèle
entre cette zone est ce qu'on aperçoit à
votre antenne et ce qui s'est passé en
ça n'a pas de sens surtout de la bouche
d'un ministre de l'intérieur
donc après ce qui a changé depuis 2014
basse et la diplomatie stellaire
l'échiquier politique international
donc depuis un certain nombre de pays
arabes se sont ralliés justement et ont
normalisé leurs relations avec l'état
d'israël notamment le maroc les émirats
arabes unis
et bien d'autres qui ont rejoint
justement la jordanie l'egypte la
turquie et bien d'autres pays qui ont
reconnu la légitimité et l'existence de
l'état d'israël
pourquoi pas mais il faut effectivement
que d'un autre côté la diplomatie
américaine et australienne fasse
quelques efforts justement de
pacification je dirais de ces zones et
de ce territoire nous que dit le droit
international le retour et l'application
justement des textes de 1967 c'est à
dire un retour justement aux frontières
de 1967 pour permettre une coexistence
entre ces deux peuples c'est à dire le
peuple il serait bien le peuple haïtien
coexistence pacifique sous mandat de
l'onu
noam anwar merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien policier et dit oria liste chez
le média